c'est un scrutin historique pour la
commune de la verrière un basculement à
droite pour cette ville communiste
depuis 1977
le candidat divers droite nicolas
dainville remporte ces élections
municipales 2020 avec 47 52 % des
suffrages
une victoire de justesse avec 58 voix
d'avancé sur nelly duthu grande joie une
grande responsabilité
un grand honneur on a envie avec
l'équipe de faire des belles choses pour
cette ville de la verrière de lui à
pulse et une nouvelle dynamique et et
c'est très important qu'on se mette au
travail dès demain pour agir sur
l'emploi sur l'éducation sur la sécurité
sur le cadre de vie dans cette
triangulaire du second tour la gauche
partait divisée d'un côté la maire
sortante communiste nelly duthu élu en
2007 suite à la démission d'alain ajaj
de l'autre jean yves blé son premier
adjoint qui en 2019 créer un groupe au
sein de la majorité avec plusieurs élus
sur fond de désaccords unis dans ce
scrutin la gauche aurait pu l'emporter
dommage peut être qu'ils aient division
à gauche et qui pense que si on
additionne au premier tour les les voix
de monsieur blé les miennes on passe au
premier tour donc un petit peu compliqué
cette division mais bon voilà je suis
pas sûr que les mesures que vont prendre
monsieur d'un guide soit dans l'intérêt
des derniers rois donc à chaque fois que
les interactions menacée mais c'est
david va nous trouver sur la sur sa
route
on a plus d'une fois essayé de tendre la
main madame je tue mais ne l'a jamais
rendu finalement je crois que là la
rupture
peut-être s'opère au départ de monsieur
hajjaj finalement on a constitué une
équipe là prêts à être à l'écouté de
monsieur dainville et à attendre
lui qui nous écoutent également le
conseil municipal d'installation de la
verrière aura lieu ce samedi 4 juillet à
10 heures au centre culturel du scarabée